real quick within an eight minute time
span while talking to the press outside
of the White House Donald Trump first
said that a hand-delivered letter he
received from North Korea was very nice
and interesting and then minutes later
said he hadn't actually read the letter
everything about this story is bizarre
Kim jong-un sent his envoy kim
gyeong-cheol to the White House and they
brought Trump a letter and it was
physically gigantic like I mean it
wasn't like a long letter it was
physically huge and we have a picture up
on the screen for the audience it's like
a gigantic envelope and it almost seems
like another way to mock Trump like you
sent him this gigantic envelope and you
make him stand there with the thing so
here is Trump top excuse me talking
about the letter how it was really nice
and how the press would love to see
what's in the letter and it was
interesting and he might release it here
is Donald Trump saying all this stuff
letter was given to me by Kim Jong Un's
and that letter was very nice letter Oh
would you like to see what was in that
letter would you like how much how much
how much it was a very interesting
letter and at some point I may be it may
be appropriate and maybe I'll be able to
give it to you maybe you'll be able to
see it and maybe fairly soon so a very
nice letter an interesting letter soon I
might release it wouldn't you like to
see what's in it
eight minutes go by during the same
interview and he's asked what's your
response to the letter and now he says
he hasn't read the letter
you send it back I know I didn't I
haven't seen the letter yet purposely
didn't open the letter I haven't opened
it I didn't open it in front of the
director right I said would you want me
to open it you said you can read it
later I may be in for a big surprise
folks so he has no idea what's in the
letter because he didn't read it just
minutes after teasing the press with it
was very nice it was super interesting
and you would love to see this letter
this has to be a guy who's not all there
mentally right because there's nothing
to gain by flowers either lying about
having read it or later lying about
having not read it it's idiocy or
dementia or some kind of serious
emotional problem I I don't know how
else I can explain this unless you know
he was saying that was a lovely and
interesting letter he meant the
aesthetics of it or the fact that I was
such a like yeah like that the presence
of the letter was interesting but he
clearly was saying at first when he was
asked what was in it he said it was very
interesting he didn't say I don't know
what was in it because I didn't read it
minutes go by and he didn't read the
letter so he couldn't possibly tell you
what his response is going to be these
would be disturbing statements from any
adult human never mind a President of
the United States let's take a quick
break I'm on Twitter at D Pakman follow
me there today's program is made
possible in part by Indo Chino the
largest custom apparel company they make
suits and shirts to your exact
measurements for a great fit high
quality selection of fabrics and options
to personalize all the details I went
into the Boston Indo Chino showroom but
if you don't have an Indo Chino showroom
nearby you can enter your measurements
online and then get a custom suit
delivered to you within about three
weeks I worked with Chris at the Indo
Chino showroom I am completely clueless
about everything related to men's suits
but fortunately he was able to advise me
and I ended up with a really really
great suit it's actually my best suit at
this point and I recently wore it
interestingly I wore it on my recent
trip to Las Vegas and majority report
host Sam cedar was markedly impressed
with the suit I had and I told them it's
from indogene oh and you can either in
their showroom or online pick your
fabric choose your customizations submit
your measurements place the order
and you've got a custom suit in three
weeks or less you can shop online at
Indo Chino dot-com or go to any of their
showrooms in North America and this week
our viewers and listeners can get any
premium Indo Chino suit for three
hundred and seventy nine bucks at Indo
Chino calm when you enter the code
Pakman at checkout that is over 50% off
the regular price for a premium
made-to-measure suit with of course free
shipping that is Indo Chino com promo
code Pakman get any premium suit for
three hundred and seventy nine bucks
plus free shipping